as the president fiddles people are
dying do you think there is blood on the
president's hands considering the slow
response or is that too harsh of a
criticism I think that's a little too
harsh he should stop thinking out loud
and start thinking deeply another day in
the round of criticism for president
Trump is the media doing an objective
job of asking relevant questions our
partisan leader is giving the
administration a fair shake let's
discuss with Fox News senior political
analyst Brit Hume Brit good to see you
tonight Thank You Shannon okay so at
peace in the American Thinker under the
headline of the unbearable pettiness of
the Washington press corps says this
every question from the press corps is
meant to impugn the president's handling
of this global event each one of them
wants to catch him in a mistake so the
clip of their questions will go viral
Brit what do you make of the coverage
well I do think that some in the White
House press corps in particular
conspicuously not to include our own
John Roberts who I think has played this
very straight and very Abele but too
many of them are still trying to you
know play the old game that you do of
you know asking these questions intended
to show that something that Trump said
previously was inconsistent with
something he said that's fine for normal
times these are not normal times that
those briefings that are being held at
the White House are really a fount of
information some of it's provided by
Trump himself although he spends a lot
of time bragging and and saying what a
great job they're doing and getting into
into tussles with reporters who ask him
annoying questions but even from him
there's there's real information Mike
Pence does a good job of summarizing
what's being done in the government and
to the end to help the states and then
doctors foul and Burks have been
excellent in interpreting the data that
are coming in day by day and giving us a
sense of how this pandemic is spreading
you know what's the good news what's the
bad news and I think people are hungry
for that I mean I I'm a political
journalist right I would you'd think I
would be the one that was most absorbed
with the politics of all this but what
I'm interested in just is a citizen
watching these briefings day after day
is what do they tell us about the
the virus where they tell us about the
pandemic what do they tell us about how
New York is doing and what its its death
rates and it's and it's hospitalization
rates what does all that stop telling us
I think a lot of reporters aren't asking
questions about that stuff and they're
missing something well in listen the
president likes to spar with them he is
game and ready to do it but he's also
taking on this idea that Governor Cuomo
in some corners is gaining rapidly as
someone who could somehow magically be
the Democrats nominee the president not
afraid to troll a little bit with that
here's what he said now if he's gonna
run this fine I wouldn't mind running
against Andrew I know Andrew for a long
time I wouldn't mind that but I'll be
honest I think it'd be a better
candidate than sleepy Joe
the New York Times under the headline
what the Cuomo 2020 fantasy says about
2020 reality says there's the Cuomo
flirtation such as it is seems most
instructive for what it says about those
drawn to it reviving a persistent trope
among Trump era Democrats the
romanticizing of prospective party
saviors even at this point in the
nominating calendar and there are new
polls out that Democrats still have
serious questions about Biden 15% of
Bernie Sanders supporters say they'll go
if Biden turns out to be the guy they're
gonna go over and vote for Trump I mean
it sounds like Democrats are still
looking for that one person they think
can be the best match against president
Trump well another reason for that
Shannon is that since his quite sharp
debate performance in his last round
with Bernie Sanders Biden's been
struggling and he's you know he's been
off the campaign trail because everybody
is and he's been doing these pieces out
of a home studio in his house and he's
had some seriously awkward moments doing
that and he doesn't have a job he
doesn't have a role he doesn't he can't
get up and and do what Cuomo for example
is doing which is too brief about the
efforts that are being made in his
bailiwick to deal with the issue and and
and and Cuomo who could be quite
eloquent at times has been
philosophizing about this whole matter
and so on and and he's been in kind of
at the top of his game and it's not hard
to understand why Democrats worried
about Biden worried about his age
worrying about his eviden
senility at times wouldn't look at young
man drew cuomo and say man he I wish he
were our horse the mechanics of it
though as the as the New York Times
editorial suggests are pretty hard to
imagine I mean we're going to have a
convention they're gonna be delegates
whether it's a whether it's a virtual
convention or an actual convention it
remains to be seen but you know the
candidates who have amassed the
delegates in the primary process are
going to be are going to be the ones
with with people voting for him in that
convention and if you don't have any
delegates you don't have a lot of
leverage that what would have to happen
would be providing to withdraw for some
reason and and and violence delegates
and perhaps some of Sanders is as well
would have to swing their support to the
last-minute candidacy of Andrew Cuomo
it's not impossible but it's highly
unlikely yeah a lot of interesting
numbers in The Washington Post ABC News
poll and they come on the day that
Bernie reassures his followers he is not
dropping out could make things very
interesting Brit Hume thank you always
for your time good to see you okay thank
you Shannon